[Applause]
here are the nominees for achievement in
film editing
don't look up hank corwin
dune joe walker
king richard pamela martin
the power of the dog peter chiberus
tictic boom
myron kirsten and andrew weisbloom
and the oscar goes to
doom
wow
wow
thank you
uh getting here i've i've had a blast
and uh but my kids they didn't really
have a choice in the matter they had to
come along for the ride like it or not
there were a lot of sad farewells in
airports and having to listen to a worm
surfacing every hour while they're
trying to do their coursework
so you may not know but the words oscar
nominated can be used in the hands of a
skilled 17 year old as an insult
[Laughter]
[Applause]
my daughter once said to me in an
argument it's all very well for you
oscar-nominated joe walker
so thank you to the academy for this
upgrade i need all the help i can get
now
nail rose and nurse guy lovely with all
my heart
thank you mary parent thank you
legendary warner
uh thank you to my team and above all
else thank you denny merci du fonduca
this is a tribute to you thank you thank
you
you